do you remember barry the first time
you heard dolly sing that song i do
it was like an explosion but when it
came to dolly's turn to sing
everything just caught fire it just lit
up and
we knew right there and then that this
was a number one record and
kenny was fine but dolly was on fire
and within two or three takes oh yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
what does that song mean to you now that
song in
a lot of ways changed my my life i'd
always
loved barry and the bee gees everything
they ever did i loved
but then when it became such a huge hit
it opened up a lot of things for kenny
and i to do together
really added many elements to my life
and to be
part of a song that's considered one of
the
greatest records of all time and
everywhere i go
people say island's in this dream
nearly 38 years later barry and dolly
have teamed up once again for their new
song
[Music]
words
the single appears on barry's new album
green fields
the gibb brothers songbook volume one i
love this album
i love this song and dolly i understand
barry called you and asked you to do
this how quickly did you say
yes as quick as i got the word that he
wanted me to sing it
i said yes i'm in i love the song and i
love barry so
i mean what else did i need that's very
true and barry
what was it like being in the same
recording studio with the iconic dolly
absolutely um incredible and when dolly
walks in
the room lights up and everything's
great you know
every other artist i know says the same
thing this world
has lost its glory dolly you've been
collaborating with lots of people this
year
including our michael buble to your
goddaughter miley and
barry is there someone who's still on
your list to collaborate with
well i don't really have anyone in mind
they just seem to fall when they're
supposed to
i didn't plan to sing with any of these
people things just kind of seemed to
happen
and when barry had asked me to sing on
words it's one of my favorite songs
ever and i've i've been singing that
song ever since it was a hit for them
years ago so stunning you know this
album
is full of people that you respect me
when you wanted to work with people like
dolly little big town
keith urban miranda lambert talk about
the importance of having the textures of
all those different voices
it's impossible because the style is
just a line it wasn't like i knew who
was going to sing each song
but without dolly i don't think these
people would have jumped in as quickly
as they did i love that